what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here I was waiting for John to come back
to do this trailer with me come to find
out he just got in a car accident
it's a pray for John and his horrible
horrible mistakes it's his fault I don't
really know the details of anything that
went down but I'm gonna assume it's his
fault hope you're watching John we're
gonna check out the next trailer for
Sicario 2 sold dog oh I really like the
first trailer for this movie watching
this from Joe Blow movie trailers and
I'm gonna give a patron the day shout
out today for none other than JT oh wow
right into the action this is not
advertiser friendly
[Music]
maybe part of the first trailer
[Music]
setting drug cartels to the list of
terrorist organizations you can
understand how that will expand our
ability to combat them you want to see
this thing through I'm gonna have to get
dirty
oh um is exactly why you're here
now start a war with hope they're giving
being
damn
Wow they've really amp it up the action
[Music]
with the Mexican government
[Music]
correct yes sir we can't risk her
falling into the wrong hands another
time
get rid of her I can't do this protect
him little girl story
Logan you gotta do what you gotta do I'm
gonna need a strike team to a Blackhawks
drone for the TAC capability or is it
good
[Music]
no reason to trust me
which cuts to me it's how you survive
good luck luck doesn't live on this side
of the border
and yes day of the Soldado now they
expanded the title there a little bit
looks like a cool action movie okay so
some positives that I like from this
trailer because they have some concerns
actually I really love the first show
but this trailer cam brought a little
bit of concerns to the plate for me I
really like the approach of taking the a
personal approach for Benicio del Toro's
Alejandro character because in the first
one the movie like sort of ends up
becoming about Benicio Del Toro's
character and he's sort of the scene
stealer in that movie he's the main
character everyone ends up gravitating
towards so to take the approach of
making a lot of the personal focus and
the stakes for his character I like that
because he was the one though we all
ended up loving and talking about when
the movie was done the first one Josh
Brolin's character the Matt graver
character seems to be doing his matt
graver thing easy now raising chaos
regan war it has me a little concerned
and i'm not sure if it's something i
should be a little weary about this film
is still scripted by taylor sheridan
it's got a brand new director for it the
film seems to really be amping up the
action and on the first trailer reaction
i was like well you know I remember the
first Sicario trailer trying to showcase
the action but it really wasn't about
the action while there was some cool
sequences in it it really had a big
sense of dread it was a unique kind of
character study of a film here they seem
to be showing there's a lot more action
sequences going down and then there are
teases of the action sequences that are
significantly bigger it feels a little
bit more hollywood it out which can be
fun which could be cool which can be
good but that's not what i think the
fans are the first Sicario are really
showing up for well we really like for
the story and the characters and the
tone that the film had the trailer seems
to be carrying some of that over which
is good but it does seem like they're
really aiming to amp up the action and
the thrills which can feel like it's for
a different type of audience and this
whole storyline with the little girl
forgetting so many movies now with
having to protect the little girl or the
little girl's a really significant piece
to whatever the puzzle is of the movie
that seems a little bit cliche to me but
then again i keep flashing back to the
experience of the first Sicario how that
was advertised a certain way
they had to market it a little bit
different to get some audiences in there
and we'll really got that movie popular
was the word of mouth of the film and
I'm hoping this does the same thing you
got the same writer Taylor Sheridan here
I know they got a different director
they even got a different composer and
different cinematographer which were
very key elements but from the people
they got they probably pretty saw a
track record of the new people brought
on board and you got the two characters
here that people were incredibly
gravitated towards from the first one I
feel like this could be a good time
regardless I'm wondering how essential
it's all gonna feel and I'm hoping that
what feels cliche about this movie is
not cliche upon its execution bottom
line there's all the nuance of the first
film I don't want to be thrown out the
window I don't want this to be just a
generic action thriller because it's
kind of how it's being marketed right
now it looks cool but that's not why we
love the first one and if you're gonna
do a sequel you got to make sure you
have that great nuance of the first one
or expand upon that don't just give us
more action thrills you still have time
to reshoot this Josh Brolin's used to
that anyway I wanted to give a patient
the day shout-out for none other than JT
JT the Japanese man from Hawaii
we're gonna be doing a Google hangout
with you next week buddy this guy's a
unique dude you know like he's a quiet
guy this dude has a great listening face
like when he listens he listens to you
we do Google Hangouts with certain
patrons a unique thing about our Google
Hangouts is I'm constantly coming up
with ideas as a matter of fact the
trailers revisited segment that people
have really been liking on this channel
stemmed from a conversation I was having
with that guy and I don't think I ever
gave him a proper thank-you for that so
thank you JT helping me brainstorm this
idea and getting your feedback on it
dude because you are one cool man and
dude you're in Hawaii where there's
beautiful babes the next time we talk
you better be telling me about how
you're getting laid left and right in
Hawaii man come on dude you're a cuddly
teddy bear and other chicks are gonna
view the same way use that confidence
get off the pornography and just focus
on real life chicks it helped me out
might help you out too
anyway guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up and you can check us
out on patreon we do weekly Q&A is what
that means is we take a question and we
do a full video response to that so
they're there individual videos and we
do full-length TV show reactions or
they would love to have you see you guys